welcome everybody to know that YouTube
hangout super excited to be here with my
friends and CEO of sage mr. Stephen
Kelly sages the accounting software that
I personally use to run my YouTube
channel in my business and it's an honor
to be here every month with him
answering questions talking about
entrepreneurship Stephen welcome aboard
right over here Evan we always love your
show your broadcast of the best arm and
it's an honor for me to be involved and
I'm very humbled so I just love doing it
because it's great fun too and hopefully
we're letting everybody out there into
kind of some secret source about how to
be more successful as entrepreneurs and
grow and expand their businesses I love
it well today we're talking about a
really important topic how do we get
financing as entrepreneurs but before
jump into that I know people always look
forward to seeing what are the quotes
that Stephen Kelly is gonna lead us off
with so I know you got some papers ready
what do you got for us this month
Stephen we got full quotes to kick it
off and first one is the co-founder of
blip TV Dena Kaplan and quietly you need
to keep your head down and build a great
product before you raise money kind of
letting it's important message then
Arianna Huffington obviously amazing in
terms of broadcast and media as well
having a partner or an investor
definitely allows you to take more risks
and go faster and then a couple of
quotes actually kind of visa Evan
Stephen quotes when raising money you
look through the lens of what happens
when things go wrong and the final quote
this is kind of cool business isn't a
religion if it was we'd have a much
easier time raising money now Evan and I
believe business is a noble course it is
it is a religion it's your religion it's
your idea and that's what you've got to
make sure you inspire in everybody who's
back in you so there you go kick it off
with a quote seven back to you I love it
so so this is something that talking
about finance saying it's one of the
most common questions about returns
I know that you have gone through the
ropes of being you know running a
startup organization and and now being
part of a much bigger company you've
done some angel investing yourself as
well before dive into kind of the
questions that are coming through from
the audience and guys watching live
leave it in the chat and we'll pick
through and starting some questions what
is your kind of overall thoughts summary
advice that you want to kick off with in
terms of best financing options for
entrepreneurs yeah I think I think
overall there's got to be a philosophy
and I'm a really great believer we'll
get into this I'm sure with the
questions of making money before you
raise money so you know I just think a
lot of people raise money too early and
I think generally you know the companies
I've seen who are like from one to
twenty people who go and raise money
typically waste money and and it's
actually connected to the culture you
want to build I'd say from day one when
you build your company build your
culture so I use phrases all the time in
here like you know treat the company's
money as if it's your own because it is
and as I've found there is a leader
that's what you want to do now when you
come on to the point where you want to
grow faster and you want to expand
quicker and you need capital there's
loads of different options that
obviously simplistically you either
borrow money through death or you raised
money for equity by giving people a
slice of the company and there's loads
of pros and conversation with those but
you know when you're starting off you
know I'm known great entrepreneurs who
kind of actually have funded their
business on the back of credit cards so
I you know I think this is where it's an
area where you've got a hustle and and
only kind of run your business in some
respects on fumes because if you throw
too much money at it too quickly you
just tend to find you'd kind of destroy
the culture and it's nice to have that
kind of hunger in your business so III
wouldn't we'll get on to the specific
means and the the pros and cons of
equity and you know maybe preference
shares all these sort of things but I
really do believe my experience tells me
Evan
so actually if you can defer as long as
possible
raising significant amounts of money and
keep the ownership of the company in
people like yourself and people you
really trust then that's probably the
best thing you can do but if you can
scale up really quickly obviously you
need to go and raise capital a lot of it
well let's get to your questions guys
leave it in the comment box that's
already starting to fill up and come in
so get them in early first up is J rise
longtime fan and friend of the channel
do you believe that any business can be
started with no money and bootstrap can
any business be bootstrapped yeah and I
think it's great when you do that
typically a lot of it depends on the
type of business so if you've got like
personal creations like art crafts
products that are a relatively low cost
and products that are dependent on your
brilliance your genius your intellectual
property then there's loads of platforms
in place obviously Amazon eBay or all
these sort of Etsy all these sort of
thing platforms that allow you to get
your product to market really quickly
and obviously you might pay a 20% turn
or something but it allows you to get
your products in the market and you can
effectively get the revenues from your
customers almost immediately and I as I
said I you know J rise I've known quite
a lot of entrepreneurs who have started
their business I've had personal credit
cards and use that as just time stamps
really debt to kick off and invest in my
products and start you know taking
leases on properties and stuff like that
in in advance of it secondly on the
other type of products or rather
services that allow you to bootstrap
your business is anything like in-home
services I don't it might be landscape
gardening you know it could be child
minding it could be nursery and if you
don't need a physical headquarters then
and this you know Toronto this great
city where evidence there's amazing kind
of service offices there's facilities
and and you can actually simply find
even companies like us who have got
either redundant properties around that
they're pretty happy to let out a
peppercorn rent
so if you've got in-home services that's
a great place where you can go and leave
the other thing obviously I've been I've
actually invested in a number of
services based consulting companies
where you're charged in your own time
out that's the place where you
absolutely can bootstrap it and actually
one of this companies I started back in
1997 as chief who they ended up chief
executive fair we had a philosophy the
first day we started the business we
actually build ourselves out to
customers and actually always covered
our cost we set out the whole operation
from day one always cashflow positive
and actually from day one profitable and
what we do actually the beauty of that
business this is kind of interesting if
you have an idea and like intellectual
capital that will be like particularly
in this case I'm giving you as a
software product we bill we started by
the consultancy company bill in our time
out you know building a nice business
but it's kind of not I'm gonna skyrocket
but it's a people business so you can do
that you can build yourself you'd be
cashflow positive from day one which is
important and we shouldn't confuse
profitability from cash flow cash is the
fuel of your business but what we did is
used a consulting experience and we had
to make sure the contracts allowed us to
do that with the customers which they
did that we owned all the IP all the
intellectual property and we built
products on the back of consulting
engagements and then we became a product
company and then actually we scaled up
and well four years later we put
ourselves on the Nasdaq with revenues of
one hundred million dollars and we were
one of the fastest growing Deloitte 50
top 50 growth companies in the world so
and that all started from a consultant
operation all cashflow positive from the
get-go and you know obviously a lot of
hard work but the really good thing out
of that is we then built a product
business and then once obviously with a
product business then you can scale
pretty much infinitely and you can have
global reach and you know it isn't
dependent on a few key people and you
tend to find with consulting businesses
you know hugely dependent on on the
people like Evans yeah I'm sure use
concerns I've used concerns it doesn't
matter whether they come from a big
branded consult
it's the people that you get and it's
not just their intellectual property
their experience but it's also their
attitude and stuff like that so it
depends on what business you in
obviously if you're gonna set up a
manufacturing plan then you'll probably
you'll need to raise capital to do that
but you can be very smart about things
like partnerships to get other people to
invest on your behalf so I think the
answer to your question is absolutely
Jay Rhys you should think about how I
design my business to bootstrap it and
really reduce the capital one potential
dilution that you have in the early days
Evan what's your thoughts yeah I think
it's a great example I think some
businesses lend themselves more easily
to be bootstrapped and others and so
what I would encourage people to do is
have this big picture have this big
dream for where you want to take your
business have this long-term game plan
for where you want to go but that may
require a lot of money that you don't
have right now so then how can you scale
that down so it's like thinking big and
acting small and so Stephens example was
great where he wanted to build this
product company out but they started by
doing services to get money coming in to
get cash flow coming in and then that
could fund the product to then go and
build the business and so whatever big
idea you have I'd be looking at how can
I start this thing smaller because that
happens is a lot of people they feel
like they need investment and they feel
like hey they can't get started until
they get investment and so you're just
sitting on this idea constantly sitting
sitting sitting sitting doing nothing
waiting for some magical investor to
come and give you the money to get going
where really is it entre part you got to
do something every single day to build
your business forward even if it's not
at the scale that you want yet because
we're dreamers and have this huge vision
where we want to go and so thinking
about how can I get started with what I
have while also looking at funding
sources and options so I love that you
shared that example of starting service
and going product next up Tim Braun is
asking do you believe in not taking any
loans like Mark Cuban believes yet if
you can do and again you know obviously
if you can borrow money it makes you
cents but typically you're gonna pay you
know interest on that and and and
sometimes there's things like collateral
you have to put up so there's all these
things come with strings attached and
actually just just a thought as well you
know I think it's the case once you
start raising money it's a full-time job
and it's a distraction from running the
business and do not underestimate how
much time it takes to go pitching but I
think Tim yet if you can avoid if you
just as a general rule I would suggest a
good rule in life if you can avoid
raising money and really focused on
making money that's absolutely what you
should do obviously there are points in
a business cycle as you grow and expand
where you will need to probably raise
money and then you know we can get on to
how best to do that but if you borrow
money then I would one actually one
thing I've I've done successfully in the
past ironically which was brilliant when
I look back on it and it all sort of
happened by accident we were in with the
customer actually a great Canadian
company back at the time everyone called
MCI yeah MCI and they're a customer of
ours and I was in there and we knew we
were gonna cash we didn't share that
with them but we said we're looking for
investment looking at and we got the
customer to invest in us and the reason
why i love that is it gave them so much
skin in the game to make us successful
and to be a great reference and tell
everybody else that we're you know
they're an awesome telecoms company at
the time so I think once you get into
the reality Tim is if you can avoid debt
absolutely avoid it there comes a time
where you can't say you need to be
really smart and if you borrow money
then obviously look at low interest rate
you know ideally low collateral but also
get the capability where you probably
have short term capability but you have
rollovers like revolving credit that's
that's pretty good and and then if you
can do not dip into it but you tend to
find what you don't want to do is almost
like have a stop stop
so you raise some money you maybe get a
year's term we don't want to do like in
month 1011 have to go out there again to
raise money you want to have the
facility where it kind of rolls over
because again once you get into raising
money it is it is a full-time job it
really is a big distraction from the
business did did MCI own a piece of your
business or that it just pre-order and
give you funding that way well they did
actually both they they did they did
some associated with basically debt but
also then they became a shareholder in
the company which is really cool
which was you know then we had so much a
lot you know it's just beautiful if you
can get your customers to fund your
business because actually it doesn't
sound crazy because if you think about
it if a customer buys your product or
your services they obviously believe
like you believe they bought your idea
and therefore the next logical step is
if they really love it that much would
they like to kind of co-invest with you
and a really nice neat way actually with
MCI is they bought equity in the company
and you know so that I'll be really
honest at the time it gave us huge
credibility because we you know we're
pretty early startup and having them as
investors you know on the website at the
time and when we went out to customers
and say well you know I'm sure I know
India they buy the product they've
invested in the company massive
credibility massive credibility so I
think um if you can get those customers
the big corporates or whatever most of
these corporates typically have a small
sort of biz dev team and if you get
access through them through as we did
with our customer sponsored the
executive sponsor and it was a beautiful
relationship and it got great alignment
it got them having shoe skin in the game
and it allowed us to grow much faster
also with a very supportive investor
that actually was completely
non-invasive they didn't want board
seats and all those sort of things that
can get in the way cool that's a cool
story um Tim my quick thoughts for you I
don't think it's a great idea to start a
business on a loan I think too many
people do that they mortgage their home
especially the start so like you're not
gonna get a business loan at the start
banks want to see that you've been
around for a couple
before they'll give you a loan and so
any loan that you get at the beginning
is gonna be personally guaranteed so
they're gonna come after your personal
finances your house your car something
that you own and it's not a great way to
start a business because you haven't
proved anything yet and so I'd much
rather you find a way to start making a
little bit of money improved yourself
that this works when you can afford to
get a business loan it's way cheaper
than going out and getting investors if
you're paying an interest rate and you
can afford it like you have some cash
flow coming in and you know you can pay
those interest payments off and it's not
coming against you in your house then
it's actually one of the cheapest ways
to be able to build and continue to grow
business but I just wouldn't do it to
start my company I'd be looking at a
loan for expansion capital not startup
yeah I think the other vo they own this
I think now a gym there's many more
options that are probably more
attractive that you might consider Tim
so obviously crowdfunding's been popular
for three or four years we'll put a
couple of links up actually around some
good articles around crowdfunding for
both early stages business hanging and
growth businesses and actually one of
our customers over in the UK a really
fantastic company called canny and they
make awesome milk products
Liam who's the chief executive there you
know again he's just a street fighter
he's an amazing operator he had a
hundred thousand pound target and he
made that I think a week before the
deadline so we'll we'll post those links
up and even have a look at that but
again crowdfunding a great if you've got
a great idea and you pitch your idea and
you can really picture on social media
as well crowdfunding is a really time
efficient way to get the funds I'll get
a lot of support but also it's kind of
non-invasive again so you don't have to
stop the business when you turn these
pictures you know when I was in the
valley having those kind of Sandhill
wrote in just south of San Francisco and
in Palo Alto and literally when we were
raising money we raised one time about
20 million dollars with VCS it almost
stopped us running the business for
about three months and we're just seeing
all these theses and again I'll be
honest guys the
species probably invest in either the
statistics like 1% of the people they
see so you just you just think you're in
a beauty parade and it's hard graft
you're burning through your shoe lever
and you could be out there selling to
customers or attending to customers so I
really think that there are time we took
Evans advice actually because we wanted
to go
really for the next stage of exponential
growth and therefore we went to the
venture market at that time but it just
never underestimate how much time it
takes yeah and the great thing about
crowdfunding is you're not giving up a
piece of your business yeah so you don't
lose any equity in your company and
you're in is you're effectively pre
selling your product or your idea so
it's a good test to see I have this
product for this new technology or this
new t-shirt of this new book or whatever
this new thing is you're trying to
launch and you get to see this is work
and you're not actually spending any
money to make it until you've shown that
you actually have some demand for it and
so it's great there are a couple of
equity crowdfunding websites but but
most of the big crowdfunding websites
like Kickstarter the ones that we think
about is fantastic because you're not
giving up anything in your business and
if it doesn't work out you know if you
don't hit your threshold you don't
actually have to grow it and make the
products you don't owe anybody anything
nobody's gonna come and take your car or
take your house if you don't hit your
mark next up is Nikki moving to angel
investing so Nikki is asking what is
angel investing and how do I ask
somebody to be an angel investor for my
business I've described question a key I
think um an Avenger invested in a lot of
business and actually one of the
startups I was involved in I I got into
investors in the early days you know
friends of family essentially what it is
is going to people either in your
network or could be customers or could
be there's tons of angel investors in
places like Toronto Massachusetts in the
butt Valley and what they do all day is
invest in early stage businesses and
effectively what they do an effectively
an equity investment so they buy you
give them some shares in the company you
give them a
or should the company for a return based
on a valuation at that point in time and
it's pretty easy easy model now the
traditional model is it's good I think
it works I would commend angel message
but I'd ask a bit more so I would love
angel investors to be able to do
something where it really accelerates
the growth of your business so they
could be an amazing mentor they could be
someone who's been on the journey in
your adventure so I don't know if you've
got a products in t-shirts or shoes it
could be a performer entrepreneur of a
clothing company who's really made it
who knows everything and can be not only
an investor almost like a silent
investor but can be a really active
coach and mentor for you to learn and
gain the experience are the other thing
you tend to find with angel investors
you might kind of at some stage as you
grow your company want them to join your
board you know small companies you can
have again someone with industry domain
experience as the chairman or chairwoman
in your company and I think you know the
key thing about angel investors is don't
just look at them for money look at them
for advice experience can they introduce
you the new customers can they make you
go faster what are the gaps that you
have in your business and how do you
surround yourself not only with
colleagues that you recruit to actually
compensate for those gaps but also angel
investors who kind of fill out the rich
canvass to make sure your business is
the best chance of success Nikki yeah a
great point I think a lot of people are
in such a rush to get money that they're
willing to work with anybody it's like
being in such a rush to have kids that
you marry anybody just to have kids
not realizing no this is a lifelong
relationship here that we're building
there's most angel investors are
actually really unsophisticated most
angel investors there's a term so I used
to be in the venture capital industry
we'd call them DD eyes which is dentists
and doctors with disposable income a lot
of these guys and as my dentist would
explain to me he didn't really like his
job and so he got to live vicariously
through
his investments and it was just kind of
bragging rights did he get to tell his
friends oh I made an investment of this
company but he couldn't really add a lot
of value to the business he was just
what they called dumb money he was just
writing a check and that's not what you
want long term especially as you're
building your business if if you're
trying to go for venture capitals the
next round they look at who your angel
investors are and it's just a whole
bunch of dentists and nothing against
dentists there's a bunch of people who
basically can't provide a lot of
experience connections beyond just
writing a check then it makes it harder
for you to raise the next round and
continue to grow and so I I get and feel
the real kind of short-term pain and
suffering if I need this $50,000 to
start my company but you want to really
make sure that you're bringing on the
right person who's gonna give you
guidance connections advice as you
continue to build and grow yeah actually
on that but I think that's such a great
point but and by the way I think you've
got great teeth so he's done a good job
ah ah ah you got great teeth but I think
the other thing I just think about when
I was into investing really actively
probably about 12 years ago and what we
also did with the founders the company
is actually say a part of the deal is
every three months every quarter will
give a day of our time up to help you on
the business plan the operating plan you
know use our network so we literally sat
down with these early stage management
teams every quarter
and gave them just invaluable advice
about what what work what doesn't work
you know how to do product development
all this sort of stuff introduce them to
other people and the other thing I think
about angel investing is if you can as I
think the reality is it's quite likely
that you will have an angel investor and
a fuel for capital that you'll need to
do further rounds so it's really neat if
you can go to your angel investors and
they've got an understanding that
they're probably going to back your
business for a number of years and there
could be follow on rounds associated
with that so you might want to raise
that $100,000 first of all
but then you're gonna raise another
$50,000 in a year's time and and so on
and so forth and it's much easier going
back to the same people who've already
got big skin in the game who get it
hopefully who they're very credible
because if you go to venture capitals
capitalists they'll definitely think if
you got a luminary kind of set of angel
investors it just makes their decision
much easier to take so kind of follow-on
rounds and also I definitely think you
know that the angel investors if they're
the right guys that and they're not
they're not the dentists and doctors but
they know your industry inside out and
they can and then they can be really
good eyes and ears and effectively give
you an insight because you know what
it's like when you you're running your
own business you're going flat out a
thousand miles an hour and it's so rare
that you get the time to sort of take a
reflective view of how we do and you
know against the plan we set are we off
track you know where did it go and well
was it not going well and if you get
your angel investors in once a quarter
and and have that sort of reflective
session you know you get so much value
out of it you get just so much insight
so much value and also then get them
doing work and doing introductions to
people introductions to new customers or
all that sort of stuff so they can be
not only investors but they can be
tremendous resources to help you grow
your business Nicky has a follow-up
question about angels does an angel
investor always have to take a
percentage of the company and what is a
fair percentage to give yeah typically
they do there are other ways you know
you could you could get and I've been
danger investor and we said we don't
want any further dilution because we
think that's in the best interests of
companies so we've got the angel
investors actually to structure a sort a
debt package for the company for a
three-year debt package and we all we
all said that and at that point in time
that was the right thing to do so they
were in a lot of it depends on what's in
the best interest of the business and
the relationship as well I think the key
thing then is that you need to make sure
that when you give away equity is
sensible now back to the kind of Evans
first point if you go and get funding
from the get-go
you know how maybe you value your
business it's just an idea that's all it
is so you know you read the papers and
you get kind of all you go online you
get crazy ideas founded at a billion
dollars but that doesn't happen often so
if you just got an idea with a business
plan it's likely the valuation of your
business is going to be low but if
you've got a customer and you've got a
product and you've started the journey
your valuations gonna be probably
tenfold what it is than just an idea so
that's why you don't want too much
dilution early on you really want to be
making money first and then the dilution
will come much more sensibly and gently
now if I most of the sort of startup
businesses the maximum realistic
valuation say in loonies Canadian
currency maybe five million dollars but
you typically expect the idea to be well
formed with a business plan probably
with a prototype product so if you think
about it at that time you you know
there's a number of variables once the
market valuation and you can set your
own valuation you can go to other people
you can look at comparators in your
industry of where you are once you get
trading then there's a load of metrics
around for each industry what the
valuation should be and typically
they're based off our for any stage
company's percentage of revenues so you
know in really exciting technology
companies you might get 15 times the
revenues and then you get you know
whether it's training revenue forward or
revenue all that sort of stuff so
there's loads of different metrics but
the kind of key thing is you need to
establish what's the market value what's
what if we were a company and we wanted
to do ultimately sell ourselves well we
sell ourselves at and what's the
valuation then the next question is how
much money do you need and again I would
absolutely argue strongly go for really
drip-feed in yourself and take kind of
as little money as you need to but get
the firepower in place that you've got
you know the next kind of three years
mapped out if you do need to dip into
further dilution and then then that
gives you a business plan where you know
how much cash cash you're going to
consume for the next phase of growth
you know your market valuation and then
that gives you you know percentage of
how much money you need to raise so
absolutely if you had a valuation on
business of five million Canadian
dollars you need to raise five hundred
thousand dollars then effectively you're
looking at potentially a ten percent
equity race and get everybody to do that
say is it's a pretty simple set of math
mathematical algorithms that just drive
the the level of dilution but and and
the other fail be honest is you've got
when you've hired people this is
something you really need to do when
you're hiring people if you give people
when they join particularly if you're
running it like a real bootstrap you're
probably going to give them some equity
in the business because you means you
reduce you know what you don't want to
do is pay people you know hundreds of
thousand dollars a year you're much
better off paying them less and giving
them a bit of equity but what you need
to do when they join is say you know
inevitably there's going to be some
dilution on the business and therefore
they might join and you might give them
half a percent equity if they're really
you know a senior manager in the company
you are in but at that point in time
you've got to set their expectations is
when you do further rounds there'll be
further dilution because you know what
what I've had this where we failed to do
this and then that we sold the company
in the end and a lot of the people who
were working for us said well I thought
I had half a percent of you know this
amazing number where we sold it for like
40 million dollars and it wasn't half
percent because we've been through
further rounds and diluted everybody you
know it's just the way it works but you
need to explain that to people as well
and obviously explain that to the angel
investors if they don't top up you can
give when you do your angel investors
you can give them sort of rights when
you do further rounds that they top up
there they're round to maintain their
percentage but if they don't do that
then they're going to get diluted so I
think it's a good idea to have a few
rules one is raise as little money as
you need to so you're not doing you're
minimizing the level of dilution but
also it drives a culture where you're
scrapping you you know you
hungry you're not wasting money secondly
it gives you the the really important
factor is when you do raise money for
angel investors rule of thumb we talked
about the previous question is user much
more than just investors and then the
third thing is just to pry the
mathematical calculation and the longer
you go on the journey and the more
success you have obviously the
valuations going to be higher and that's
what you want to do this
that means there's less dilutions and
you hold on to more equity yourself I
love it the detailed answers I love it
Nikki I would agree with you know pretty
much everything Stephen said you know
angel investors are typically people
take an investment in your business they
take equity there's people who will give
you loans but they're not really
considered angels so for the sake of
most discussions an angel investor
someone who owns an equity piece in your
business in terms of the percentage you
know you want to think about how big can
your company get you know are you just
doing this neighborhood mom-and-pop kind
of store are you trying to build
something huge and so what we would do
when I was in the venture capital
industry was project I look five years
so like in five years where's our
revenue gonna be like how big can this
company get because for an for an
investor looking that deal they don't
know is this gonna be a hundred million
dollar company it's gonna be a 1 million
dollar company right it obviously
impacts the size of the investment and
so understanding how big that company
can grow and then kind of discounting
that valuation back to today you can
come to an assessment of how much like
see if I said how much you need versus
how much the company is worth a really
good angel investor that will also
understand that they don't want to take
too much of your company like a really
good angel investor won't come in and
take 40% of your business because they
know this is gonna be future rounds and
you're gonna get diluted and diluted and
diluted and then if you own 10% of your
company do you still have the motivation
to get up every day and drive really
hard to build this business forward and
so a smart angel and this is where you
want to find somebody again that we've
talked about who's done this before
who's mentor people along the path this
isn't their first deal
because if you get diluted down to
almost nothing you're not going to have
the incentive to want to keep working
yeah as a rule of thumb Evan is you know
when I've angel invested its timidly
I've taken between about 2 and the max
my ever talk was 10% equity and and then
actually on on most the investments I'm
investing them I exercised the top-up
facility so I maintain my percentage
ownership as they went down for further
rounds and the you know I think to Evans
point as well it's really good because
just mentally what are you doing with an
angel investor you you're pitching to
him so so what do they want to know
exactly what Evan said they won't know
what the market opportunity is what
could it look like in five years time
you know have you've got a coherent
business plan to execute the growth
what's your value proposition what's
your unique selling point have you got a
plan a you a credible person have you
done this before have you have you got a
plan if you've got three or four other
people in place that's the management
team how quite how much quality is the
management team in terms of the
execution risk and all those sort of
things but you know then set their
expectations that get someone in or you
can there's loads of stuff on the
internet around valuation of companies
and the good the actually the good thing
I'd say the smart angel investors they
weren't nickel and dime you they won't
screw you on the valuation because also
there's a there's a few disaster cases
right you never want to do a future
round that's a down round and what what
I mean by that is you don't want to
raise money and then basically the next
round you come up with a lower valuation
you came round at the first round so
everybody you know it's really it's
tempting I suppose to give yourself a
ridiculous valuation in the first round
and say we're worth you know I don't
know 50 million on the base of an idea
but the risk then is the next round you
do when you kind of need money is you're
gonna have a down round and you're gonna
have investors who kind of really are
disenfranchised so I think you've got to
be really sensible and that's also why
you want to raise as little money in the
early stages until you're making money
because then when you're making money
evaluations going to be sustainable and
higher
next fault question comes from dar who's
asking is it better to find an angel
investor or raise money from friends and
family I think probably you know and it
typically tends to be a bit of a mixture
and and the other thing though is you
know and I know and I've had this when
I've been in companies a lot of my
friends have said oh how can I invest
it's great and particularly if you've
done it once or twice before and you've
been successful then everybody kind of
wants to join you or your bandwagon
I'd say the big difference is if you can
get angel investors who really add value
in terms of the growth of the business
and coach and mentor and support you
that's what you really want to go for
and and then you know if I had a ratio
maybe I'd do ninety percent of the money
I raised her angel investors and maybe
ten percent through friends and family
but I'd make that friends and family
very small the other thing you know by
the very nature you don't want to be
distracted by all your friends and
family coming to ask you how the
business is doing every day and you get
loads of emails from them and stuff like
that you you want to be running the
business and putting all your energy and
passion into growing the business so you
kind of want your both your angel
investors and your friends and family to
be low maintenance and that's why I'd
suggest if you do get angel investors
it's a really good thing that you kind
of control when they have access to the
company maybe once a quarter once a year
you know don't owe to a review of the
business how we do and where we're going
how we grow in when it's likely good
you're gonna need more money to set
their expectation you know in a year's
time we're gonna be coming back to you
and asking you for more money because
we're gonna grow faster and then you
know maybe take them out for dinner or
drinks or something like that and then
it means that you know there's a
specific time slice when they know that
you're gonna come to them and give them
an update on the business well you don't
want to do Diaries have all your friends
and family say my house of business
doing you have to spend all you time
turn everybody how is it doing I'd also
say final thing is you don't want too
many of these folks you you wouldn't
want hundreds of friends and family you
want to constrain it just to maximum
odds probably half a dozen
maybe maybe maximum ten to twelve but
you don't want to you don't want to
dilute you know you don't want to have
everybody having like point zero zero
zero one percent of the business because
it's just all sets a lot of admin
paperwork you need to get an attorney
probably to draw up a share agreement
all that sort of stuff and it's cost and
distraction yeah Dyer I would say one it
depends on how much money you need to
raise so if you know how much money you
need to raise if you're looking at under
fifty thousand dollars you're probably
going the friends and family and not to
'angels you know if you're like I need
five thousand dollars you know an angel
investor doesn't want to invest $5,000
it's just not worth the time their time
to look at your deal and do the due
diligence and get to know you the return
isn't gonna be there for them so if you
know that you need less than 50k I'd be
looking at friends and family first off
instead of angels the other thing to
Stevens point I'd be looking at okay do
I want my friends and family involved in
my company is Uncle Joe now gonna want
to be you know an adviser to the
business and do I want Uncle Joe's an
adviser to my business is this gonna
cause issues when we have Thanksgiving
dinner together or Christmas time just
those kinds of things to think about
sometimes when you mix money and family
it can go really really wrong sometimes
it can be great you know some of the
first people that I brought on my team
were people my family I've had amazing
relationships working with my family in
different different paths but a lot of
people can't do it as well so you just
want to pay really close attention again
back to our point talking about angels
it's great that you know you need that
money and here's a short-term option for
you but you have to remember this is
gonna be something that you're gonna
have to deal with for a long time and so
do you want to take Uncle Joe's money
and then have to deal with the
consequences of that yes evidence is
great when things go well but if you're
there at the Thanksgiving dinner and the
business isn't doing well and you have
another investment round that's lower
than Uncle Joe put in before you know
you're gonna get ninth degree
of burns from the questioning so it's
almost like you know when you if you do
friends and family I'd the quote I gave
they're going to when you're raising
money especially with friends and family
look at look at the lens of what happens
when things go wrong so you know we hope
we don't go wrong but I think the you're
right Evan it's all about the quantum if
it's a small quantum it makes sense but
you do have to again I guess the reality
is as an entrepreneur we're always
optimistic aren't we we're always
optimistic you'll always believe in your
idea but when if you raise money with
friends and family you have to kind of
give them that government health warning
a thousand times saying it could go
wrong you could lose your money so don't
bust my chops if if it all blows up and
you lose your money you know it's a risk
but the upside is if it goes well would
do well but I you know then want to fall
out with you in two years time when you
know we're shutting down the company and
I'm moving on to my next big idea so you
just got to be really honest with them
because otherwise this is you know
friends and family you could have no
friends and family if you do it wrong
and they thought you screw them out of
us very very true okay next up chart
your trade I have both a service and a
product as part of my business can you
get angel investors for just one part of
the business I'd like it for just a
product part of my business is that
possible yeah I guess it depends how you
structure your company but it sounds
like it's a bit complicated but you
could have like an overall company and
then two companies sort of beneath that
the product and services company and
then you can raise money for the product
company and ultimately you could then
you know some state if you want to
consider an exit Salem is independent
businesses so yeah it's definitely
possible there's ways to do that and I
think obviously on the product side
typically it on the services business
hopefully you can do that instruction
out that's cashflow positive from day
one but on the product side it does tend
to need you know greater investment and
as I said I guess a neat way of doing
this you know if it's other things like
technology space or software or products
that come from the services
if they're related as a business if you
can get the monies and the cash you're
generating through the services business
to fund the product business that's a
great way of doing it but I think yeah
Emily possible doing what you want to do
and you could kind of set set up two
separate companies to do that and then
have a company that owns both companies
overriding it it's totally possible the
challenge will be trying to convince an
angel investor to just find one part of
the business because the concern from an
angel is going to be well why are you
spending time on this other thing yeah
okay you know I want to make sure that
angels want to make sure that you like
everything you have is going into making
the thing that they're investing in work
and so their concern is going to be if
your time is split between two or three
different ideas and and they're only
invested into one of them then that's
gonna be a problem so from from a
technical point of view you just need to
set up a separate business and you can
sell shares in that company that's fine
it's just a sales point of view it could
be a real big challenge getting an
investor to buy into that idea that your
time is going to be split and you want
me to invest money only into one idea I
think that's gonna be your challenge
especially if your other ideas making
money like if this new product one is
the one that you want to launch any
funding for but your other side of the
business is more establishment is making
money
the investor ideally is gonna want to
have a piece of the other one because
there's a little bit more guarantees a
little less risk involved so I think
it's gonna be a challenge if you try to
get it going yes philosophically as well
Evan I think it actually this is maybe
strange advice to give but with these
sort of things with angel investors I
would encourage the founders and the
entrepreneurs to be generous I think you
know in that example an angel investor
would feel very uncomfortable about a
prior you know having to invest in one
side of the business not having total
skin in the game on that side and not
playing on the other side of the fence
so I
generally I'd say why not be generous
and give the angel investor the
opportunity to enjoy the outside on both
sides of the business and I think you
know it's fun aliens would quote from
Jonathan Swift actually says when it
when it comes to money it's all about
the head but what it really should be is
about the heart as well and I think you
know I would I don't know why people
become really sort of selfish and they
lose their personality because I think
most entrepreneurs a huge optimistic
very generous and I think you want to be
quite generous with your angel investors
because they're back and you they're
gonna give they're gonna give their
personal time their commitment probably
their own reputation by picking up the
phone to introduce you to various people
and and it's a real it has to be a real
win-win where where I'll definitely
advocate be generous with them and most
of these ng investor everybody talked
about this probably probably would look
for something like a tenfold return that
would probably a good benchmark but
there at the the other good about things
about the angel Buster's they know when
stuff goes wrong because they'll have
invested probably in six seven eight
companies and only one in six kind of
work out but that one in six is giving
them a tenth of return so so I
definitely share share the upside share
the downside yeah we didn't talk much
about expectations for for angels I
agree so you're looking for a tenfold
return and they're also looking for an
exit path so it has to be clear how how
are they going to get their money out of
this business
I usually if somebody's gonna buy you so
they want to see a path that something
will buy your company so like who's an
acquisition or how can you be an
acquisition target for somebody else it
could be I'm gonna take my company
public and that's gonna be our exit is
going to be an IPO but so few companies
actually go and IPO that really it's how
are you going to get bought out in ten
years and if your plan is well I never
want to get bought out I want to I want
to run this company for 50 years and
pass it on to my kids and grandkids that
starts raising alarm bells to and that
okay well buy invest money into this
company how am I ever gonna get anything
back
is going to be a noun multi-generational
family run business and so just
factoring that in if it's a percentage
of profits or some kind of payment plan
something's that as an investor if you
know going in like this investor wants
to be able to make ten times their money
in maybe a ten year period how is that
going to happen yeah actually we there's
a couple of other things sort of related
to this and and you want to see if you
run the head and see how the movie plays
out so definitely IPO which is an
initial public offering you go on the
Nasdaq or you go on the Toronto exchange
yeah that's very rare so you've got to
think of a sale and exit until you
that's known as a trade sale now one of
the brilliant things and I've been
involved as an angel in a company that
did this is they even from day one they
thought about where is the likely places
we're going to get acquired and they
actually got an investment from one of
those companies because and we've done
this actually we bought a company back
in March where the year before we'd made
a 20% investment and and it's kind of
try before you buy because then
everybody gets to know you get to know
the management team you get to know the
chemistry the culture they're like the
product so a really smart thing to do is
get an investment from a company that
you want to be bought by and let them
either white label your product or or
whatever and and form that relationship
because then it becomes a really low
risk for them to do an acquisition and
buy you out the other thing I'd say
actually we didn't talk about this
either
is you know my experience with angel
investors they want you to put all the
money you're making back in the business
so you know if they want to do things
like dividends and stuff like that
doesn't make sense you shouldn't be
taking money out of the business you
should be keeping all the money in the
business so it's angel investors they
need to know that there's an exit plan
they need to know they're gonna get the
money out but they're also typically
well the typically time horizon might be
five seven years if you get lucky it
could be three years but that's the sort
of horizon you're looking for an angel
investor and tenfold return no dividends
so no profit share or anything like that
all the
it's get plowed back in the business
because you want to grow grow grow and
grow faster so we started off this
session talking about loans and we moved
a lot to angel investing and Yousef is
asking so which is better getting a loan
or angel investing what are our thoughts
so when when should you go for either
option it's a lot of it's about the time
in stage and quantum so probably earlier
on I you know very early on it might be
a little bit of friends and family as
you scale up I quite like angel
investing with people who've got real
skin in the game and a lot of experience
and I would use loans pretty sparingly
really - Evans point but you know
fundamentally again it probably depends
on how much investment you need to grow
and what cap you require in the business
but my general philosophy and a lot of
it biased by this because most of my
experiences where I've been an angel
investor those companies tend to be kind
of much better run much more involved in
good management teams hiring a good
people and equity at share of an equity
really does create a great culture in a
business because you you everybody's an
owner and we say you know there's
something called founders mentality I
mentioned last time check it out on the
web type in founders mentality it drives
a great culture it's about custom
session it's about all the things that
really matter in the culture of business
and you get that from ownership where
you where you borrow money and you
raised it I think you get less of that
but obviously you know needs muss and
you're probably going to have a mixture
honestly as you grow and expand
you're probably gonna start with some
friends and family then you'll get some
major investment you almost certainly
have some sort of revolving credit
facility and you might for short periods
of time
take debt so generally I think go the
long haul raise equity short term
requirements typically alone yeah so
with all of this we want to try to raise
as little capital as possible because we
want to you know try to keep it to
ourselves and be able to grow but but
you need cap
to expand offs in the business if you
can get a business loan and not a
personal guarantee loan a business loan
that's going to be your cheapest form of
capital because you're paying three four
five six seven whatever percent interest
on it which will be way less to you than
giving up a chunk of your company if you
look at okay I'm gonna grow over the
next five years how much is that going
to cost me
but that assumes that one that you have
the cash flow to support the loan and to
you you are confident in your team and
your ability as people to go out and
execute bringing on angel investors and
people on your team really you're doing
it for yes to money but the expertise
like if I bring in mr. Stephen Kelly
angel investor extraordinary into my
business how much does that help my
company's reputation Stephen picking up
a phone you know making some calls for
me that that experience that wisdom that
mentorship that trust can really explode
your company forward but it's about
really finding the right person to bring
on board and not just treating them like
a bank account yeah good of us good
qualm Mel Mel's taking us up the next
step you these exact urate about the
difference between angels and venture
capitalists and our thoughts on those
two yeah and you know again it's it's
not completely binary there can be
overlap where angel investors can also
be venture capitalists and also venture
capitalists partners can be private
investors as well so mama I think is a
good question again it's typically the
stage of a business you probably start
with friends and family then you move on
to Andrew investment and then you go on
to venture capital and then you know
typically when you're dealing with
venture capital in normally millions of
dollars typically and they'll they'll
look at you know the management team the
market opportunity the business idea you
probably you know there's all whole over
the series series ABC at different stage
of the company so you can be a pre
product idea and you can go and raise
our VC money typically the reason why it
tends to be later stage is if you go
very early then you get massive ty
Lucien because these VCS you know
normally would be 2040
of the equity of the company and
sometimes you know they'll bill look at
even more than 50% so you lose kind of
the ownership of the company then as
well so there's it's a trade off is to
trade off there's not kind of one right
answer but I think the other thing if
you do do look at the VC route it's
pretty good to tease out the partners of
those VCS to invest as angels and I know
a lot of VCs you know typically these
are really wealthy people evans worked
in the industry you know they're they're
driving Ferraris and all this stuff
private jets they normally then and
they're normally very experienced people
they're normally got great networks
again if you get into the VC world I'd
make sure that they bring expertise of
your domain and experience typically the
other thing actually sorry to say on VCS
they want quite a lot of control of the
company they want board seats normally
one or two board seats and all that sort
of stuff so it just tends to be when
you're at a later stage of a bit more
grown-up company so then that the amount
you want to raise makes a huge
difference like these C's if you want to
raise a hundred thousand dollars they're
not interested in you it's just not
their game right and and that may be
beyond the stretch of your friends and
family too to write a hundred thousand
dollar check so that's where the Angels
come into play right so under 50k you're
looking at friends and family 50k to
three hundred four hundred thousand
dollars like VCS really don't want to do
those little small deals really anything
under half a million they don't really
want to touch they might because they
see you know long-term potential but
really they want to be doing that the
twenty five fifty hundred million dollar
deals and if that really stuff kind of
helps something they'll do it but under
under half a million really you're
looking at angel investors and then
above a half a million that's a hard
check for an angel to write like not
many angels will write a five hundred
thousand dollar check to you so that's
where you get into the VCS VCS also want
you know the ten times they return
they'll have a much more aggressive path
than an angel
so they
want to happen like ASAP they'll they'll
blow you up for growth or just blow up
your company and the same idea of one of
ten works out well they've made their
money and they don't really care so much
what happens to the others a lot of them
end up blowing up yet eleven is ideally
you want to have angels who are
connected to VC network and the VCS
would look at your angels if they know
them they're highly credible individuals
that helps you massively the other thing
you find on VCS a lot of them kind of
want to create syndicates so there's two
or three VCS are all coming together and
you know you'll find in the West Coast
people that benchmark all these sort of
guys will actually form great
relationship with other VCS and they
tend to hunt in packs but you know let's
let's now kid ourselves when you get VCS
involved it's great when the business is
going well but boy oh boy if you have a
couple of bad quarters you'll find them
big you know you'll find those bald
meters become pretty brutal and even you
know they'll be forcing things like
changes changes of you know the new
management team so you lose a lot of
control say just yeah walk into it with
your eyes open another thing that I saw
a lot of when I was in the VC world was
investors new investors coming in don't
want to buy out old investors so what
would happen a lot of times is people
would raise money from angels dentists
and it would you know go live and they
built their business but the dentist is
just some silent shareholder and they
want to buy them out because they're not
contributing understand that no investor
wants to come in just to buy out
somebody else they want to see that
their money is going to be put to use to
grow the company so that's why the first
investors that you bring in are really
important because if you bring on
reputable angel investors and then they
go to a VC they'll actually help you
like their name their credibility of
their experience and contacts helps you
get that next deal where if you're going
with somebody who has no experience and
it's their first deal and they're not
contribute anything they actually hurt
you because when you go and create your
pitch you're also showing who's involved
on your team look who's on your Board of
Advisors or Board of Directors and who
you're in
your investors are and it's a bunch of
people that nobody recognizes that's
gonna hurt your ability to get the next
round
yeah and this if you do get involved
with VCS there's kind of a few things
you want to do kind of rule says there's
loads of embel just pick three one is
always manage their expectations
so typically under-promise over-deliver
secondly is performance becomes
excruciating because they will want they
won't want quarterly board packs they
want monthly reports so one a lot of
evidence to know that you're working
their money well so performance is
everything and third things kind of
don't do what they consider stupid stuff
so I've been sitting in an early-stage
company have been going pretty well and
then the CEO said actually you know
we're going out doing a little round and
I've actually like to take a little bit
of personal money off the table buy a
second home now that's stupid you know
you don't want to hear like your chief
executives saying I want to take some
money off you want to doubling down you
want them to put you know and and this
was a case at you all the executives put
their own money into the business which
we haven't talked about and when you're
hard people absolutely give them the
opportunity to do they want to invest in
the business because wow if you've got
someone you've hired who puts their own
money in the business and actually earns
equity wow that is awesome that's a
great way to raise money and that's
something you should ask them you know
if they are that they may have been made
redundant they've got a check from
somewhere they've got some inheritance
what why not back back themselves and
back your business and actually be an
investor because then you've got massive
skin in the game you know those guys
work so hard for your success it's a
great great formula I love it well
stupid is crazy how quickly an hour goes
by we've answered a ton of questions a
lot more ki-moon that we didn't have
time for but thank you guys for joining
us Stephen last word goes to you a quote
or some words of wisdom to sum all of
this up what do you got yeah I think um
you know it's a great topic ever today
and I think great questions out there
and really appreciate everything you you
kind of asked us I think it's a rich
topic I hope we've helped you but with
all these things you know
with everything tree tree the company's
money as if it's your own because it is
and even when you raise money from other
people just treat it as if it's your own
and the most important thing is kind of
be smart see how the movies gonna play
out think ahead and and really when you
go and sell you a big idea just think
when you're going to invest as though as
important as when you're pitching to
customers and do a great job in terms of
pitch and idea and when they're on board
you know manager expectations hopefully
blow the blow they've kind of knocked
the ball out of the park and
under-promise over-deliver because
that's what all investors want they want
you to come and say would place a
quarter we closed a year we actually did
a little bit better than we thought
always sort of under-promise and
over-deliver that's a great message for
anybody addressing investors I love it
well thank you sieving for the great
advice thank you guys for watching if
you want to give us suggestions for the
topic next month leave it in the
comments below not the live one because
YouTube deletes all that but after this
video goes public leave it down the
comments below and we'll consider it
thank you guys again continue to believe
and we'll see you next month
great job love Evan